you say cyrus est bienvenu un coup de
fil c'est partant j'ai mangé une pomme
bon a priori on s'en fout mais moi je me
pose une question est ce que j'aurais pu
ne pas manger cette pomme
certes m'aurait dit oui beaucoup d'entre
vous aussi mais je veux un avis qui me
disent non je veux celui du déterminisme
de spinoza spinoza c'est un philosophe
qui est né à amsterdam qui est juif
d'origine portugaise donc il a sûrement
été conçu dans un club échangiste samro
têtu il se fait exclure de la communauté
juive à cause de son idéologie sur dieu
qui l'a développé notamment dans les tic
un livre qu'il a mis toute sa vie à
écrire et qui est sorti après sa mort
alors qu'il a mis toute sa vie elle est
créée dès le début du bouquin et
l'arrivée à pau ses cacahuètes en disant
que dieu et la nature c'est la même
chose
donc en fait tout ce qui est est en dieu
et c'est la seule substance de l'univers
donc ça va vous complètement ce qu'on
pensait du à l'époque donc tout est de
cette substance qu'il appelle dieu la
nature du coup ces substances
elle est la cause de tout donc elle est
la cause d'elle même donc on ne peut pas
ne pas être c'est à dire qu'elle est
nécessaire et en fait il n'ya pas de but
dans l'univers et tout ne fait que
suivre l'ordre des choses et cet ordre
il est déterminé suivez moi on est
surdéterminé fait rien ça fait très mal
quand on marche dessus
oui déterminée sert qu'en fait tout ce
produit sur l'enchaînement nécessaire
des causes et des effets comme par
exemple dans la vidéo dacia tomic sur
l'étrange histoire de la white if i'm on
voit plusieurs causes comme le fait
d'attendre l'ascenseur levé que brice ne
sache pas fermer la portière d'une
voiture etc etc qui vont entraîner un
accident
mr ouai j'avoue je suis désolé mais je
me suis permis ce que je crois que c'est
un bon exemple
ouais c'est vrai dans ma vision à
manches et non d'actions et d'événements
abouti sur une triste conclusion chaque
action tire sa cause sur les actions qui
ont précédé donc c'est bien du
déterminisme l'a fait gaffe mais c'est
pas pour autant que ça reste une
fatalité
allez je te laisse qu'un mec puisse mec
alors effectivement aux états unis qui a
raison c'est un fataliste pense que tu
mourras demain il dira que quoi que tu
fasses que tu fasses du saut en
parachute que tu restes chez toi
eh bien tu mourras demain si c'est écrit
tu dois mourir demain comme dans
destination finale où tu ne peux pas
échapper au sort qui t'attend genre
cette pauvre fille qui à son ordi qui
lui tranche la gorge puis sa cuisine qui
explose avec un couteau qui lui tombe
dessus qui se fait lui-même enfoncé par
une chaise il ya de la joie
bon alors qu'un déterminer ce que dira
que je mourrais demain que si les haies
les causes qu'il faut pour que je meurs
demain mais je pourrais très bien ne pas
mourir ça dépend des causes du coup
j'aurais pas pu ne pas manger ma pomme
parce que si je dis que j'aurais pu ne
pas manger ma pomme ce serait admettre
la possibilité ça n'arrive pas alors
qu'à ce moment là il y avait toutes les
causes pour que ça arrive donc ce serait
admettre de la contingence c'est-à-dire
l' inverse de la nécessité tout est donc
l'issue d'un enchaînement de causes
même tes choix en gros spinoza réfute le
libre arbitre
je ne fais aucun choix avec monsieur le
juge c'est un concours de circonstances
qui m'a poussé à tirer sur la gâchette
ces modifications mes gènes la situation
c'est des milliers de choses à prendre
en compte
je n'ai pas choisi monsieur veut
je ne fais pas de jouer je suis je suis
déterminé d'accord non coupable mais
attention il réfute votre libre arbitre
et panoplies berthet parce qu'en fait
pour spinoza notre liberté elle réside
pas dans le fait de faire des choix
en gros pour lui la liberté ça ne
s'oppose pas à nécessiter la contrainte
je suis libre si j'agis selon la
nécessité qui vient de moi c'est à dire
si je suis mon conatus alors le conatus
c'est l'effort de persévérance dans son
être ces genres par exemple la plante
qui pousse le cheval qui galope l'homme
qui pense ou qui désirent genre t'as
schopenhauer qu'il appelait la volonté
fraude qu'il appelait la libido
enfin bref c'est un concept finalement
qu'on en connaît tous
en revanche je suis contraint si j'agis
selon une nécessité qui est extérieur à
la mienne comme avec les passions et les
affects
par exemple si je suis triste ça va
diminuer mon conatus du coup notre
liberté ça va être de réduire ces
nécessités extérieur et donc de
comprendre nos affects et nos passions
pour moi les subir en gros pour
schématiser une paire qui roulait qui
tombe est libre une pierre qui tombe
mais qui rencontrent des obstacles qui
lui empêche de rouler correctement ne
l'est pas la pierre c'est non le fait qu
elle persévère dans son mouvement
c'est le conatus et les obstacles et les
affects et les passions donc en gros on
a la liberté de connaître les causes de
ces actions mais on n'est pas libre
quand on fait un choix important séjour
ou parce que moi conçu un choix j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'être libre et
ben en fait il expulsa par une citation
assez importante qu'il a sorti les
hommes se croient libres parce qu'ils
sont conscients de leur désir mais
ignorants des causes qui les détermine
en rompant spin-off vu qu'on n'est pas
conscient de tout ce qui nous pousse à
faire tel choix est bon on pense qu'il
est libre voyages je vais donner un
exemple que j'aime bien imagine qu'ils
étaient dans une pièce et tu dois
absolument sortir parce que par exemple
ne sais pas il ya un incendie
ouais ouais je fais des effets spéciaux
et il ya de porte à porte à il apporte b
donc soit je fuis en passant par
apportera soit je fus en passant pas la
porte mais je suis dans mes deux portes
je choisis j'ai vraiment l'association
d'être libre lorsque je fais mon choix
je passe par la porte noire ok en fait
il s'avère que la porte avait été fermé
toute façon donc j'aurais pas pu passer
par la porte mais de toute façon je
serais passée par là portera
si j'avais su que la porte b été fermé
parce que j'avais fait mon choix
j'aurais pas du tout eu cette sensation
d'être libre
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut avoir la
sensation d'être libre par l'ignorance
est un bon gars parler mes petits
conseils ça tu le sors en soirée tu
paies shaw direct quoi tester un nom
cité que tenant que tester en fait
acheté j'étais pas très en forme ce soir
là j'espère que le déterminisme de
spinoza est maintenant plus clair pour
vous hésitez pas checa description peut
avoir plus d'infos et à partager la
vidéo si vous ai appris un truc
en attendant je l'envoie du love et de
l'abysse